um so when did you decide to run
um actually as the premiership of boris
johnson was coming to a close and uh
became obvious i looked around the table
uh looked around the party and i thought
that there's probably three things that
we'll need in order to both win the next
election and lead the country we're
going to have to have complete
competence we're going to have to be
able to communicate and we're going to
have to be able to campaign and when i
thought about what i've done in the
parts um including helping to win the
2015 election when i was party chairman
and the way that i've taken quite an
unruly department department for
transport didn't always have the best
press it was often the news for the
wrong reasons
and run it very i hope people agree
confidently
i think actually i can use the same
approach with the country and uh improve
britain i think our best days lie ahead
and i think i'm the person to deliver
that okay i'm keen to talk a bit more
about your pitch a bit more about
yourself as the interview goes on but
just to talk about the last week because
it's been pretty extraordinary you've
obviously had a bit of a ringside seat
to it you went in to tell boris johnson
frankly that he didn't have the numbers
what happened yeah i mean look i always
just think that the the best thing to do
is be completely candid and just you
know
say it as it is and um i can see that
you know things were coming to a close i
i didn't want him to be i mean one of
the problems is being a leader
eventually you get people around you
who'll just tell you what you want to
hear and i just wanted to make sure that
he was getting the facts uh and and that
was my conversation uh with him and he
uh listened carefully and and as we know
the next morning
said that he would he would stand out
did you think it was
part of the the reason then
yes i think i mean
it's presenting the reality so yes of
course and what was his mood like
i'm actually on the evening that i saw
him he was still quite uh buoyant and
you know i as i say you know
he's always looking for
um and for him i think it was a question
of public service he he's a huge kind of
drive to sort of but we've still got so
much to do he was saying and
and i said that that's that's right but
you know i've always
been straightforward giving you the the
numbers as i see them and i just don't
think that's going to be
possible i think that you know one way
or another and it's been endlessly
debated many times on your program
despite all the brilliant things that he
was able to do in including
um progressing and you know with brexit
uh where the country had already decided
and sourcing it out and the way that we
were the first country in the world
to put a vaccination
an authorized vaccination in in
someone's arm margaret keenan's arm and
come out of coronavirus lockdowns the
first as well and all the rest of those
things his leadership in ukraine despite
all of that
the problems within
um his government and particularly the
operation of number 10
were just insurmountable
what do you mean by the operations
number two well clearly the parties just
you know in the end um uh
you know
we were all locked down we're all having
to
i couldn't see my dad for four months as
i've told you before and he was in
hospital and uh you know thought we'd
lost him
you know in the end um those who make
the laws have to live by the laws and i
think that just made it impossible it's
interesting because i've obviously
interviewed you you know throughout the
code pandemic quite a lot of times
you're often the person going out on the
most difficult weeks to be frank
it must be quite hard to defend
speaking to you now you yeah i mean look
i'm i'm i'm free to tell you obviously
exactly what i think
if you're in a government you have
something called collective
responsibility in the cabinet uh you
have to make decisions around that
cabinet table and then the agreement is
you stick to those decisions or you
shouldn't be
in cabinet and there's obviously you
know huge number of things this
government has been um doing from
tackling a global pandemic for which
there was no textbook there was no rule
but we had to you know first time in 100
years there's been a pandemic like this
and we had to you know essentially make
it up as we went along and i think
actually overall given the speed of the
vaccine roll out we did a very good job
but but
um you know my head was down in the
department and you know looking after
transport and everything else um but you
know i think i said at the time and i
repeat it now of course it was hugely
uneasy about
you know having to
uh to to talk about things which i was
uncomfortable with not least because of
my own family experience did i think on
balance that that necessarily overruled
the really great things that were
happening um no um i i actually thought
we were doing so many good things
particularly lately with ukraine
um that i that i wasn't you know unlike
um you know some of my colleagues came
to the conclusion it was over i i didn't
think it should be do you think um boris
johnson's a man of integrity you know
what actually like all of us he's
fundamentally flawed but we all are as
human beings right
in different ways perhaps in different
ways i think actually you know one of
his um
uh failings was he was sort of almost
too loyal to to people when we saw it's
a session of people who he would
definitely like chris printer for
example well um
pincher um
you know uh people would have said
cummings and and other people uh
but but uh you know
in the end um he was also quite brave
he'd take decisions that you know i
think other politicians would have
perhaps said
is that brave or is that reckless i
guess and that is always the decision or
that the the quality of decisions is
then really under the spotlight you say
that it was about you know showing
loyalty to people and some would say
that that's quite a positive spin to put
on it when actually it's it's integrity
it's also about your relationship to
truth and being frank with people yeah
and and look i mean i think there's no
doubt there are differences there were
times when you know if i had been prime
minister i would just have come to
a different decision um
as i say i think you know in many ways
it's brilliant in some ways it's flawed
actually you know everyone have has that
blood plus as a miner's history will
judge that in the round
um in the sunday times today you said i
haven't spent the last few turbulent
years plotting or briefing against the
prime minister i have not been
mobilizing a leadership campaign
behind us back who are you talking about
no one in particular no no no come on no
there are people who um have for quite
some time wanted the prime minister um
to go many of them are on the back
benches and not being plotting
leadership campaigns so who has been
plotting a leadership campaign then um
from cabinet well look i i just simply
i'm not going to get into it you can't
you can't say
that i'm not just inviting you i'm going
on what you've said in the sunday time
it's entirely intended uh to be a
positive campaign a positive comment
about my campaign which is i've looked
after my department i've had my head
down i've run it competently so you're
not going to worry about risky i'm not
no i'm not actually and i think rishi's
a great guy i think all these candidates
and she has just heard
tom say i think all the candidates we've
got an almost an embarrassment of good
quality candidates and i simply am not
going to get into attacking them i like
all of the candidates we're actually
included a lot all i would say is my
work has been you know dealing with
things like the the kent lorry crisis
where macron closed the border calling
in the army fixing that dealing with the
biggest repatriation this country's had
since dunkirk when thomas cook went down
uh looking after the hgv crisis where we
had the fuel crisis at our petrol
station that's what i've been doing in
my department head down doing that now
we're on a leadership contest i want to
point out to people that i think i can
communicate to the country i think that
i can run a very competent ship in
number 10 and i think i can campaign i
think i can win my colleagues who are
the electorate immediately their seats
well let's let's talk about your quality
shall we you obviously missed a
spreadsheet um you correctly predicted
the number of people who would uh back
boris johnson in his leadership campaign
you got i think the confidence vote just
won out so your spreadsheet's algorithm
is pretty good
what does your spreadsheet tell you
about whether you're going to get to the
next round honestly well i think i i
will obviously otherwise it wouldn't be
um what is the spreadsheet well and i
hope you'll forgive me i'm not going to
go into like
and for you to say obviously but i think
what viewers love to hear about is my
plan for the country how i think we can
make ourselves the biggest economy by
2050 and help literally we will we will
get into that process i'd love to talk
about those things i don't want to go
into spreadsheets but you've got you've
got you think you've got the numbers but
clearly i wouldn't be here if i didn't
think that was okay right let's talk
about policy and you served both david
cameron and boris johnson yeah what is
your ideology yeah so i look i believe
in a lower tax uh lower regulation cut
the red tape uh economy uh where people
are free to uh
where the government's essentially
actually lowers the barriers for
individuals and businesses to achieve
the best possible uh things they can in
their in their own lives and i think
the role of the government is to help
with that but sometimes that means
reducing taxes it means being able to
reduce red tape make it easier to deal
with government get on with your life
start a business bring up a family bring
up children
and that's what i what i what i want to
do and within a framework within a
long-term plan of making this uh the
best economy
in europe by 2050 the largest economy in
europe which is a big ask and we need a
plan to get there let's talk about taxes
what taxes specifically do you want to
come down well look i think very first
thing we are in a cost of living squeeze
and i think the reduction which is
already planned uh 1p off uh the income
tax rate the basic rate that should
happen now if i become a prime minister
we'll have an emergency budget we'll
introduce that immediately i also want
to stop
freeze if you like the proposed increase
in corporation tax if we're going to
rebuild this economy if we're going to
you know beat the rest of the world it
is we're going to create the jobs that
we need the high-tech jobs we we cannot
send the signal to business that you're
not welcome here and
so that is a that is a tax which will
not go up and i'll pay for all of this
by making sure we cut the cost of the
state okay that's interesting because it
does feel like at the minute in these
leadership contests everyone has talked
about tax cuts corporation tax cut
national insurance and it's expensive so
you are being open that you would cut
spending in order to do that yes i mean
look our government spending just to put
this in is 1.2 trillion pounds a year
right and it's gone up yeah without pay
for an awful lot of things of course it
doesn't of course it does but it's gone
up because of um coronavirus but you
know uh i mean last year public spending
was um i think 52 percent over 50 gdp
and what the danger is that never quite
comes down again
where would you cut them well gordon
brown even even gordon brown i should
say used to say that you know public
spending should be no more than about 40
percent of the economy
where would you come because this is
where we get yeah of course of course
well let let me just sort of give you
some examples there are nowadays many
more efficient ways of doing things so
to take my own area of transport uh
there are still 60 000 pieces of paper a
week being sent to the dvla agency that
look after people's driving licenses and
the like we you know that takes a lot of
administration a lot of bureaucracy you
can lower costs by using technology you
can't decide
one simple example i understand but it
just feels like you know just by saying
efficiency savings this is what everyone
talks about
billions and billions here you're going
to have to make some difficult and
potentially controversial choices and
spending if you want to pay for it but
here's the thing again department of
transport department of transport we
have five and a half thousand people
working there now in 2016 it would have
been half of that size now we've had to
deal with you know the upshot costs of
of brexit and dealing with all of that
we've had to deal with coronavirus
dealing with all of that you know but
there must come a point as a government
and this will be the case across all
government departments where you sort of
say hold on a minute what's going on in
2016 people weren't saying government
isn't big enough uh and so now twice
decided give us a
meaty proposal where you'd can't spend
it yeah so well let's start with the
size of the civil service and government
i would certainly look to reduce the
cost of doing government i think that's
really important civil servants well in
in you'd partly do this through
attrition of course and sacking sounds
very very very harsh but you you know
you simply stop employing people in in
post you allow the thing to come down
another great example again from my area
sorry there's obviously things that i i
am very invested in i am at the moment
in the process of taking on the rmt the
union who still operate under rules from
the 50s and 60s one case a rule from
1919 which is that you can't necessarily
ask people to drive on on a sunday and
in doing so we over man um some of our
public services in some ways which
aren't even safe so in the case of
maintenance for example rather than
using technology trains that could do a
much better job with 70 000 images a
minute on the railways of checking the
railways instead we have people go along
and walk along the railways i'm
interested and that's dangerous and so
over
public services so do you think that is
across the across the board in lots of
different public sector so i do so i do
think across certainly government
departments certainly the agencies that
i'm most familiar with but there is one
area which i would expand and that is
the army the military because uh in my
view i were paying the costs for years
of skimping along just barely getting to
the two percent sometimes of uh defense
spending uh as against our gdp when our
nato commitment is as you know two
percent i think we need to put that up
to three percent i think we're paying
the cost in the war in ukraine for not
having done that and whatever else we do
under a shaft's administration we will
make sure that we are paying for our
defense and not skimping on it okay
um are trans men men and trans women
women well
first of all i should say if uh if
there's a chaps administration i'm prime
minister i will not be spending most my
time on these kind of um issues i think
we owe everybody love and respect i uh
people should be able to get on and live
their lives there's clearly a biological
uh
basis upon the you know
your birth but when people want to
gender uh transition gender that is uh
that is their choice and they they'll
always have the support uh from me
as i say i think the country is far more
interested in things like their cost of
living um the bread and butter issues
jobs and the rest of it
i mean some of your rivals are talking
quite a lot about the war and awoke do
you think that's not actually where
people's heads are if people want a sort
of a pm who's talking about sort of the
war from work
or woke issues at all it's just not me
don't vote for me i am interested in the
bread and butter issues that your
viewers will be thinking about every
single day of the week i i am a
libertarian i'm i'm liberal both
economically but also socially let
people live let people live their lives
i just don't think we need to get caught
up in some u.s style you know debate and
sort of almost sort of aggressive war
on these issues it's just not necessary
okay um now you have had a couple of um
scandals i think maybe is a bit too
harsh a word but at the same time
there's certainly been some controversy
around some of your time in uh office
in 2015 you quit as a minister after
allegedly uh failing to follow up
allegations of bullying in the party
when you were chairman and this is you
know quite serious because it did lead
potentially uh to the suicide of a 21
year old activist
is that something you still think about
absolutely but i just must correct
something there because there was a full
uh independent investigation into it
that there's no uh indication at all
that i ignored um berlin that's not what
the investigation uh did at all and i
actually resigned entirely as a matter
of honor as far as i was concerned i
wasn't party chairman when i resigned it
this was months later i wasn't there
when the bullying took place either
i was very frustrated frankly upset with
the party at the time because the family
of the the the individual who very sadly
took his life were asking for answers
the party was sending in the lawyers
rather than having a conversation i was
still a government minister though this
is a
month later i was in the foreign office
and department for international
development and i was very upset and
distressed that i couldn't just go and
speak to them because i was banned from
doing so i thought the honorable decent
human thing to do was to resign and i
was pleased afterwards i was able to go
and speak to the family and i do not
regret doing that and of course i think
about them all the time okay
um you've had two experiences two
experiences in your life where
you know you've perhaps been confronted
by your own mortality
i was quite interested to read you know
you were in a coma for a week after you
had a car crash when you're 21 you were
29 when you were diagnosed with cancer
have these experiences changed do you
influence you um
i i i was in a in a coma and i had a car
crashers in in the states and a friend
of mine um was a british friend of mine
i was driving and we ended up through
the oncoming highway and and uh and the
car tumbling um and i was lucky to to
come through it i was very pleased i
remember waking up from the coma i was
very pleased to be coming around i knew
something bad had happened but not quite
must have been strange experience very
strange and i can't remember the crash
itself your brain just erases it um but
you know i made a full recovery i think
i may have been 20 rather than 21 at the
time made a full recovery and then as
you say 10 years later i had uh i was
diagnosed with hodgkin's lymphoma now
anyone watching knows the day when you
hear the news you've got cancer
it's like a scene in a film where
everything stops around you and
you it just you suddenly face this
this brick wall i just been selected as
a candidate for my seat that i
eventually went on to win uh well in
hatfield um and i remember calling my
party chairman and saying i'm sorry i
think i probably have to stand he said
well let's speak about it in three
months time let's see how you're doing
once you get into your chemotherapy in
mind actually we never spoke about it
again and obviously the rest is it's
history um
i was a year in chemotherapy and
radiotherapy through to the end of that
but it was all before i i came into
politics the strange thing is talking
about it it feels like i'm talking about
somebody else's you know it's so long
ago it feels like a bad dream but but it
was
as anyone who knows who's gone through
these things very significant mainly
actually
it meant that we would have to have
children through ivf because of the
chemotherapy and all three of our kids
are through ivf so it had some big
impacts on our lives of course
um i gonna end if i may by doing a bit
of a quick fire sure around
who's your biggest rival in the contest
i i actually don't know my spreadsheet's
not even telling me that yet so look
let's just see how this develops this is
day one so i think it's a little bit
early to say
you come on you i don't believe that i
just don't believe that your spreadsheet
isn't telling you
no
i think there are lots of great
candidates some haven't even launched
even people who are um who have been
talked about a lot haven't even launched
yet so let's see how this settles down
i'm confident i will be in the next
round i really think that i have a plan
for this country i think we are we are
we we need that kind of leadership and i
think i can offer it um would boris
johnson get a job in your cabinet i
don't think you want one the answers no
have you ever done drugs no
what was your first job
uh the first thing i ever did was to
work for a company called nashua later
castetna and it's one of the things that
led me into setting up a printing
company 32 years ago what's the
naughtiest thing you've ever done i've
been terribly naughty actually i haven't
run through any corn fields or anything
else
i haven't even been naughty enough to
run through a corner i'm just not a sort
of natural uh a natural rebel like like
that not like theresa may not like not
not on that agent scale right okay and
what's your proudest moment i think
actually
something that people don't know about
but i once set up a um
an app which is called street link and
it goes to this day and what it does is
enables people to if they see somebody
who's homeless to enable them to come
off the street and get the help and
support that they require i set that up
more than 10 years ago when i was a
housing minister i'm so proud the other
day when i checked it's helped thousands
of people off the streets and that's the
sort of compassion that conservatives
might like to see okay got chaps thank
you very much for being on the program
today thank you thank you